Personnage secondaire
je
non monsieur parce que je vais vous attraper
Cela ne fait que trois ans depuis la fin
de la seconde guerre mondiale et le voici
sur le point de commencer une poursuite
Fabuleux avec toi le poète Pablo
neruda je peux écrire les vers plus
triste ce soir ils disent que neruda est
le communiste le plus important du monde
Je suis persécuté au dernier lieu du
monde où j'aurais voulu ne pas
s'est passé ici un après-midi, le Seigneur
le président connaissait ces doutes
retour mais allons à la
Je suis vraiment désolé de ne pas le faire
Je peux passer dans le pays je t'aime
vouloir
Tu ne peux pas imaginer à quel point je t'aime où
sera
Je vais devenir ton pire cauchemar
tu veux être trouvé
Je voudrais me sentir plus proche
doit être quelque part
raison
dans cette fiction nous tournons tous autour
du protagoniste a un principal et un
secondaire
qu'est-ce qui se passe que vous voulez une évasion
super pour qu'on se bat caméra
l'artiste a voulu dans les romans
la police poursuit le meurtrier jusqu'au
final
Je veux être actif dans ta mort
et je serai le personnage principal
ça doit être une chasse